I love to watch my son direct I just
love to sit there and watch him direct
the pictures tell you what I don't I
like I don't like when he puts me in a
picture and then he takes me out
well that's not fair I went so hard she
was cut out a taxi driver she was
Travis's first passenger you had to go
that's it I took you out what else did I
take you out of Raging Bull you took me
out of two yeah well you were only an
extra day
no but you were you did a big scene in
king of comedy you did the whole
conversation
oh the whole scene of king of comedy
with the De Niro down in the basement
his mother arguing with him it's all
improvised between the two very good I I
thought of that all myself all by myself
he gave me two words and he says
continue yeah right she wrote it wrote
down her own dialogue I used to tell him
but I'm not an actress he sees to say to
me but you don't have to be an actress I
said but I don't know how to act he says
mother you either get in the picture or
you pay money I didn't have so I had to
get in the picture
main streets they gave me 28 and I
couldn't say nothing 28 dollars